[Musique]
la vaccination c'est est large et depuis
aujourd'hui au plus de 75 ans ne vivent
pas en maison de retraite et à près de
800000 personnes présentant des
pathologies à haut risque cela tombe
bien
andré cools on vient de fêter ses 90
printemps à partir d'aujourd'hui il doit
pouvoir se faire vacciner mais il faut
prendre son mal en patience
je voudrais me faire vaquer la musique
canet près d'antibes 40 personnes
accueillies oui oui uniquement 40
personnes pour l'instant tout simplement
parce que n'ont pas ses doses de vaccin
plm montée en charge
la situation est ubuesque puisque à ces
centres oui on leur avait promis des
milliers de doses sont une semaine et on
les a rappelé ce week end pour dire à
tous les maires ce ne sont pas des
milliers de doses ce seront quelques
centaines si on restait sur un rythme de
10 mille doses par semaine il nous
faudrait environ huit mois pour arriver
à vacciner uniquement les plus de 75 ans
la dernière ses questions ses douces un
tout gros s'ils voulaient donc
effectivement passé 80 ans et plus
difficile
envisagez-vous une grossesse dans les
trois prochains mois voilà c'est le
questionnaire médical pour les gens de
plus de 60 au nom de l'accord aux gens
ils ont cinq jours pour se rétracter on
doit avoir l'avis d'un médecin la vérité
il faut vous la dirai ce qu'on a c'est
de là que ça ou est ce qu'on en a pas
assez
j'entends qu'il ya des responsables de
l'opposition qui à chaque fois qu on a
avancé dans cette crise sanitaire ont
cherché à instrumentaliser les choses
pour critiquer le gouvernement
moi ce que je dis c'est que on a un
certain nombre de doses beaucoup de
doses qui ont été préservés réservés
nous sommes en flux tendu c'est notre
stratégie de la stratégie de l'allemagne
de l'italie de l'espagne de l'angleterre
de tous les pays aux réalités qui
vaccinent on ne fait pas de stocks
cachés au contraire dès qu'on a des
vaccins ont les déployant protège des
français qu'ils nous disent clairement
quelle est la réalité des stocks dont
dispose le pays
est-ce que c'est s'en vont pouvoir dans
les tout prochains jours dans les toutes
prochaines semaines
continuer à vacciner à vacciner
massivement nous n'avons pas de vaccin
ou de stock caché quand quand voudrait
garder pour nous pour pas vacciner les
gens qui y en a quand même y en a il y
en a pas parce qu'on l'ait planifie on
va produire en france dans des usines
dans des entreprises françaises du
vaccin pour pouvoir augmenter à cerner
fillon c'est en discussion où ils sont
en train de regarder si c'est possible
de le faire mais nous sommes
effectivement en train de regarder avec
sanofi s'ils peuvent débloquer des
capacités de remplissage de flacons de
vaccin parce que ils ont des grosses
capacités en la matière l'appel à la
grève demain des salariés de sanofi le
groupe pharmaceutique français distancé
dans la course au vaccin anti qu'ovide
prévoit la suppression d'un millier de
postes dont 400 en recherche et
développement secteur pourtant crucial
rappellent la cgt nous avons lancé un
projet avec sanofi d'une très grande
capacité de fabrication vaccinale qui
puisse être mise à disposition des
français au moment d'une épidémique
puisque il est possible que cet
événement la cua récurrents ne soit plus
isolé dans le temps ne soit plus un
minimum historique qui arrivent tous les
trois siècles il ya une enquête qui a
été fait d'ailleurs intéressante par
nice matin laurent hommage là dessus qui
a démontré que les chiffres de santé
publique france d'hospitalisation qui
étaient ceux sur lesquels se basait le
gouvernement pour prendre des décisions
étaient des chiffres qui n'étaient pas
les mêmes que les chiffres du terrain du
chu et on va du simple au triple la
vaccination est un immense espoir et je
vous le répète on va tout faire pour
qu'il se concrétise tout faire on entend
des mais il ne serait pas responsable de
ma part de vous dire ça y est la
vaccination se déploie elle s'accélère
et vous allez voir qu'elle va fortement
s'accélérer pendant les semaines à venir
mais elle ne suffira pas de symptômes à
31 ans si vous voulez je me laisse le
choix de pouvoir éventuellement un jour
faire la politique si j'en ai si je vois
personne présidentielle mais pour la
suivante voilà non disparition
héros faussement râleurs faussement
désabusé adoré des français jugent pas
faux curé la fragilité actuelle
enfin serge suis pas je ne vais pas vous
défendre ce à quoi agiter acteurs
samoussas aura plutôt tendance à me
gonfler mois